hi my name is Sarah Goodwin and I'm here
today with Lewis right heart who's a
professor of Neuroscience at the
University of California San Francisco
and Lou is a very successful neuro
scientist and he's also known throughout
the world as the first American to
summit k2 the first American to summit
both k2 and Everest and on his
expedition to Everest he led a team that
were the first to ascend and summit
Everest from its east side and this
route has never been repeated thought
we'd start with how did he begin
climbing well I should say as a kid I
was very athletic and I think that's
true of many scientists I mean they
don't they aren't very intellectual as
children particularly if you're a boy
and my family went on camping trips i
mean i'd say the mountains were at least
the most exciting thing in my life in
some ways and so it was natural to want
to explore in the Sierras which are a
wonderful place to explore and this
included trying to get to the tops of
the peaks and stuff and of course even
these things like walks when you're
young seem like a huge adventure and so
I just loved it and so then it went on
from there basically what got you
interested in science well I I got
interested I went to Harvard as an
undergraduate and I really thought I was
gonna doing the history or something and
I was impressed I I mean at that point
if he there were two things I mean one
of them I did take a biology course that
Jim Watson taught and it was a time when
basically the whole concept of DNA the
RNA to protein was just being discovered
the triplet code and so on and so it was
incredibly exciting you know compared to
reading endless thick books on Russian
hisses ours or whatever and so that was
a very strong motivating factors what
was your first big expedition well the
first one was to Mount McKinley actually
which I'd say was it was purely by
chance a friend knew a friend and I
never even thought about this and I just
say Mount McKinley is an absolutely
magical experience and everybody we are
there in the early summer yeah the it's
very glaciated you're on these huge
glaciers these
and well it goes down the light never
disappears and so you get this
spectacular light on the on the snow
purples oranges greens that you can't
you don't see anywhere else I think in
the world except in the High Arctic and
so you know we were successful though we
spent 12 days in the storm we in a lot
of cold and very little food grad school
you went on the expedition to Mount
McKinley what about when you were doing
your postdoctoral research well my
postdoc actually I did us i should say
these expeditions i did two expeditions
one was an expedition to dollar gary and
this was just after i finished a Jane
coffins child's fellowship was our
second expedition to dollar gary and
when we were successful in and then I
did another expedition from when I was
at Harvard between a postdoc with paul
patterson and Torsten Wiesel where I
went to Nanda Devi in India you took a
lot of challenging routes up some of
these mountains why did you decide to
take different and new routes well I
mean I think it's like science I mean
there's no point in doing something that
has been done before actually I mean
it's particularly hard to justify taking
all that time just to repeat or out I
think that you know just like in science
you try to do something new you try to
do something that's not in other
people's footsteps so I have to say in
terms of the beauty the interactions of
the people i mean much of what you get
from these expeditions doesn't involve
climbing at all so I thought we'd talk a
little bit about your expedition decay
too so when did it happen and how did
you prepare yourself to go on this trip
well the k2 expedition was in 1978 it
was something I should say that every
American climber would have given their
right arm to go on they've been this
history the Americans had tried k2 in
1938 1939 where they had a very tragic
accident 1953 where they had this heroic
rescue art Gilkey then the Italians had
come in and snuck them out
1954 with Kevin yelling and like a deli
and it actually had not been climbed
again until it was climbing by a massive
Japanese expedition a year before we win
and so when I got the chance to go which
I think was because I've been on a non
tu Devi expedition which was actually
where we did a quite difficult route and
say it's an extraordinarily long
approach it's more than that two-week
tight to base camp and so you have a lot
of time to get into shape actually so
when you go on these expeditions do you
expect to summit k2 trip I had one child
at this point another on the way I went
there with being very very cautious
actually and I did not expect to go very
high on the mountain and so the summits
were very far from my mind and in the
end at this trip it turned out it was a
we had gotten the permanent really not
at the ideal time of year because it
involves some political influence of
Senator Ted Kennedy with zulfikar ali
bhutto who gave us the permit but they'd
already given the british a permit for
earlier in the year so we had to show up
late and so we ended up and really what
was the monsoon system in the summer in
Pakistan where we spent sixty eight days
above our base camp and I'd say at the
end it was sort of it wasn't survival of
the fittest it was whoever was left
standing and so there were four of us
that were left standing her and so we
had we got very lucky at the end that we
got a break in the weather and were able
to do it but it was far from sure thing
so once you reached the top of k2 and
started to come down there are some
challenging moments could you talk a
little bit about that it was very late
in the day five in the afternoon and i
was extremely cold because i didn't have
oxygen I felt I had to leave my partner
was on oxygen and he had a park and was
much warmer and he wanted to take
panoramas and so in the end since we
could not use ropes I left before he did
and we made very different decisions
that I
didn't have bivouacked near and he had
bivouac gear and so I came down through
the difficult stuff and managed to find
the tent around eight or nine at night
and he just cited about 700 feet below
the summit that he would it would be
dark before he got to the difficult part
and so he just made the decision to
bivouac and I think it went okay for a
while because he had blue a stove but
then he lost the in changing the
cartouche is he lost a little gasket and
he was smart enough he was inside a
bivouac sack to realize he couldn't
restart a stove without a gasket or you
just have an explosion and so he had a
cold night that came down himself the
next that we had two people that had
come over to join us and they climbed
them out in the next day and actually
much better style and and they came down
but that night that they were we're all
cooking water and they did make the
mistake of changing actually one stove
old I had another stove lit in the tent
so they had a huge explosion which we
all just sort of like the assembly
firefall they're kicking all their tents
all their sleeping bag stuff and you see
all this flaming stuff going down the
slope and you hope there are no boots or
something in this and so then they said
well they had to come over and spend the
night with us which we did but it meant
we couldn't cook anything and so the
next day we were very dehydrated two of
us it turned out were that two of the
people were very tired and so all we did
we got down one camp below where we had
a little food no gas and nothing to
sleep on except we slept on top of ropes
basically and we had another long day to
where we actually met some other people
on the expedition we're a big storm came
in and i should say if we'd been stuck
high in the mountain that we would have
been in very difficult shape just
because we had no provisions at all and
at the bottom it turned out that my
partner Jim wickwire who'd gone to the
summit and walked down but he
progressively gotten a weaker and sicker
and so at the bottom it was clear that
he really needed to be evacuated we
tried to arrange a hela copter
evacuation but the Pakistani helicopters
would not go that high so our Porter's
who were balti Porter's so the shi'ite
muslim had come in to take the
expedition out they'd had to spend an
extra day without food because we were
slow and because of wick wires condition
and they carried him out over the whole
length of the glacier about 60 miles
really heroically I think saving his
life and so it was one of the most i'd
say memorable moments in the mountains
for me to have people that we did not
have particularly close relationships
before we came but to see how this sort
of human need absolutely brought the
best out of them because if for some
reason my partner if jim had not lived i
mean it just would have destroyed our
whole sense of what the expedition was
worth it's over we were and I think
continued to be profoundly grateful to
them for what they did see summited
Everest in 1983 what was it like to be
on the top of that mountain I was
wonderful I mean his terrific experience
we were there in wonderful weather I
mean were there did not too late me out
in the day so we spent quite a long time
there I think at least an hour it was
like a warm Sierra snow day in the
winter so you pioneered this new route
up Everest while you were an assistant
professor at UCSF how did you balance
these two major endeavors I had not
thought of doing anything after k2 but
then Diane Feinstein who went to China
in 1979 to Shanghai to set up a
sister-city agreement it was the very
first time when the Chinese in the sense
we're opening up to at least the Western
world and so her husband Richard Blum
asked for an Everest permit and got it
and I did not know either at the time
but they contacted me afterwards I think
that you know dick is a very successful
investment banker and he loves the the
Himalayas he done a lot of trekking and
in Nepal but he hadn't really ever tried
to do anything like this and so it seems
like just a spectacular opportunity I
mean people had not been into at least
Americans had not been in Tibet since
1950 and they're not been as serious
expeditions to Tibet since the nineteen
thirty the British expeditions to
Everest in the 1930s and so it was the
wide open it was it had every element of
adventure in it why was the route of the
east face of Mount Everest so
technically challenging because well I
had a 4,000 4,500 foot buttress at the
bottom of it and the first fat probably
1,500 feet was quite steep but very good
rock then you had a very long ridge
which when we went in 1981 was very
heavily corna stand so this is very much
like some of the Peruvian ridges that
you have then we had an ice gala that we
had to climb up which we called the the
bowling alley and this was of course
because rocks did come down it and we
set up a camp at the top which we called
pin setter and then we had about 800
foot largely overhanging face which was
generally quite good rock but it was an
altitude of between 20 and 21 thousand
feet so it did melt out in the summer
and what this meant is that because
there was water freezing and thawing
that in fact there were very large hunks
of rock that could come out and so it
was you know we we used many many
different ropes on this face simply
because we are worried that rocks would
cut any one of them
and we didn't want to have more than a
couple of people on the face at a given
time because worried about somebody
above kicking down a rock on somebody
below and so then up above I'd say well
there was a very again instead of a 700
800 foot run out of fairly steep ice but
pretty straightforward ice it wasn't and
from then on it was probably the easiest
guy climb up the mountain but but it was
this bottom route part of the route
below 20 1500 feet it was especially
challenging and I should say that when
we started it you couldn't really see
your way to the end of it so when you
see something like that is it
intimidating or its profound it's hugely
intimidating i mean you say how can you
do this but it's not so different from
science or if you think about it and if
you want to solve kela mirrors or
something I mean you have you don't even
know what you have to know to solve the
problem in many cases yeah and so you
just take it step at a time and hope for
the use your best judgment and hope for
the best you so what do you think made
you such a good Mountaineer I just pure
chance and I should say I think that you
know it does pay to think about things
and many of the many Mountaineers that I
know our excel din sort of professional
lives I mean Henry Campbell for example
won a nobel prize in physics and was a
wonderful climber in Yosemite and also a
wonderful Mountain photographer there
are a number there are many many
physicists in the mountaineering is that
and so it's clear that scientists sort
of like this and I think part of the
reason they like it is because it
involves a sort of same metals trying to
solve problems that excellent a much
shorter time span off and then in
science both mountain climbing and
science are very mentally challenging
with uncertain outcomes do you see a
relationship between the two and do you
think the similarities between the two
helped you be successful in each one
well I think that you know there are
said there's similarities in the sense
that success is very uncertain i should
say the consequences in
of losing a partner our earth somebody
are much more serious than having a
study section destroy your grant not
like your grant and again that the it
provided some balance to me in the sense
that I knew what ever happened to me in
science whether I always first to
discover something or second to discover
something got a paper into seller and
got it into some lower journal that
these consequences were just simply
didn't have the same consequences even
Iran mice my sense of being as a human
being or self-worth or whatever as what
had happened in the mountains and as I
say so because the mountaineering is so
much more intense I think you're much
more like a the friends even people that
I had profound differences with on at
some point on these expeditions i should
say we have bonds that i think it's very
hard to equal in science
you